I gotta another game that we should play?
Let me bring Chris back in.
All right, Chris.
Hi, I'm just taking, I'm
taking notes on your banter.
Oh my god, what a flex?
You got a laminated script.
it's a notebook of notes.
Wait are you on a green screen?
Oh. You're on the green screen background
with your father on the phone call stall.
My father taking a call.
Who is still alive but
the age of this photo
it could be like oh don't make fun of it.
Cause like he could be passed on.
No, he's definitely alive and he looks
pretty much the same.
All the hair is gone.
[Dan] Ah.
Which let me know my
hair was gonna be gone
and sure enough.
There we go.
Aww.
Yeah.
Look good in a hat though.
Some people can't.
I can't put a hat on. My head is too big.
Well, I like I like just wearing hats.
And then when you start losing your hair,
people think you were
wearing it to cover up
the fact that you're losing hair.
For me. I'm very. I love being bald.
Because I have a bald head head.
You know what I mean?
You look really good
Yeah
with that.
(mumbles) dance? You
know. I have two horns.
You have two horns.
Just like...
Yeah. But they they're like
curly curlicues, like two pigtails.
You ever seen a pig's tail
that's like little curly
have two of those.
But it's solid bone.
They're pinny ram.
(mumbles)
That's very nice.
The doctor said I should not be allowed
to be alive. Yeah.
I agree with the doctor and
but you know, you overcome.
This is such a conversation for people
that have not talked to anyone else today.
(laughs)
Like this is simply the first
person you've talked to.
And you know, it takes
like a shitty general act
to like call my girlfriend
and be like, Hey?
This is what a human being say.
I want to play a game with you guys.
It's impossible to get off of a Zoom call.
I mean, there's no really
polite way to do it.
That I have yet to find.
Because there's no excuse you can't,
you know, you can't get off
and say like I have something to do.
Everyone knows you have nothing to do.
So, we're gonna to play a game
called Escape the Zoom.
Based on "Escape the Room."
From 2016's
hottest attraction.
So you have a certain amount
of time to try to get off
of a...
Zoom call with me in a polite way.
Mm hmm.
So, it can't be overly rude
but you do have to get off
of the call and am a do
everything in my power
to keep you on the call,
being emotionally abusive.
So well. We'll start with Rachel and Dan.
You guys are trying to wrap
up a Zoom call with me.
Oh. Yeah no.
No, I just making like sourdough.
I gotta a sourdough starter kit.
And you know, it's just about
like putting in the time
and I guess you get you get better.
You hear the baby?
I do. actually speaking of sourdough
I think our baby's poop
smells like sourdough.
So, we gotta go change your diaper.
Oh, I would love to see the baby.
There's no photos of the
baby on the internet.
Bring the baby in.
It's not a problem at all.
It's hard.
I'm an expert at changing.
The baby is covered in shit now.
And she's
Oh.
it could take a while. Please.
This happened to me Wednesday
I that I am no (indistinct)
to this.
I fell in the tub.
I like to poop in the tub.
So we pee in the shower.
I poop in the tubs.
It's all the same it's all pipes.
It used to bring it in it's totally fine.
No no, she'll it'll get
shit like it'll get shit
everywhere and and you know,
if you were here you can help
but you obviously can't.
So we just gonna go we got go.
I think spread it around they're saying
that there's a lot of stuff in the manure
and stuff that could actually
Nobody saying that.
attract COVID.
No and also like her
shit is like it's yellow
like mustard. It's not like actual shit.
Listen I've seen way worse
things on my hard drive.
The things I say
Baby is like losing it
right now.
She's losing, she's losing
her mind right now.
So now we gonna have to go.
We now gotta have to go.
I put audiences to sleep.
I could put a baby to sleep .
Then but she doesn't need to
sleep she's covered in shit.
Like in fact, it would
be if she went to sleep
covered in her own shit.
She might suffocate on
her own shit right now.
Every second you talk to
us makes us worse parents.
So, we really gotta go.
Oh.
Listen, then let's get more eyes on this.
It takes a village they say.
So, let's I'm here to
be that village for you.
Yeah.
You know, I just been
thinking about,
you know, different cultures
and what I can do to help.
You know, I just always
feel like I've taken--
Not your job. You shouldn't
be thinking about that.
Yeah. So.
Out.
You're right.
So what did you guys
Oh.
love like after after having a baby?
(mumbles)
I mean,
you back to having sex.
It's not gonna be a conversation.
Bye.
Oh, that's rude.
I feel rude.
Oh, no.
(laughs)
(laughs) Oh no.
Okay, get off of a Zoom call.
So, Chris any notes for
them anything that was rude.
I think that they were lovely.
It was very hilarious.
I am very worried about
that shit covered baby.
(laughs)
Right. I'm in the wrong in that situation.
(mumbles)
What a way to sell your baby out.
Yeah, and also guys selling
his sadness (laughs)
Right?
I was asleep up with babies.
I'm a very I was also covered
in shit at some point.
So, Chris, same thing you have
and you're very good at this.
You do this all the time to me.
You have a certain
amount of time to get off
of a Zoom
meeting with me.
Ah, I guess this one's a general.
We were talking about upcoming projects.
(laughs)
Mh. Love this.
Yes. So, Snapchat is doing a lot of great
things right now.
You know, I mean, there's
a lot of harassment there.
But it's just about, you
know, finding the right people
there. And I'd love to bring you in.
For snapchatters.
I would love I would
love to be part of that.
So I think we should circle back, man.
Um, cause I
Yeah.
gotta go to the (mumbles)
I've been circling you
for a while for this project.
Yeah.
And it's kind of like, it's
like me and you talking.
Right? And you kind of just
are explaining racism to me.
You know.
Okay.
And other white people are
like what is the big deal?
Why are people on the streets?
What's your actual number
so I can actually call--
Let us keep things professional right now.
And just on Zoom, I'll have my assistant
which is actually just me
with a different email.
Reach out with the phone number.
Oh, great.
Yeah.
Who? They have me reach out
and I'll reach it back out
once you reach out.
And then we'll circle
back. We'll reach around.
You know, we're gonna get it done.
Absolutely.
(mumbles)
And I want to talk to
you about my experience
at the Black Lives Matter protest.
And to say was for me
That's sounds fun.
me to be outside.
You know, it was so odd.
You frozen.
What is, what's going on.
Oh, no gotcha.
I still see you hear me.
Can you hear me? Can you hear me?
You know what?
Absolutely.
I'm a start it over am a reset.
Oh.
Okay, can you hear me?
I think I can hear you I
think just keep talking
cause I was about to go into my idea.
So if hear me that's fine.
Okay.
If you can here me that's fine.
Okay. I can't no.
Oh, that's his crotch and I'm off.
I'm off Zoom.
He got out.
Oh, he left.
That was good.
Oh, that was good.
Legitimately out and that's
a real problem for the show.
We don't have the actual
technology outside of the show
to bring him back on.
Oh.
Chris really, really was so polite.
He entertained some of
the worst ideas possible.
(laughs)
One of the most problematic
(mumbles) You had so
many thoughts on racism--
Oh, man.
And Black Lives Matter
and like other people would have just
given you the middle finger
and he really listened
as if you're opinion matters.
(laughs)
So I think our winner of the
game was put it in the chat.
Who do you think won this one?
Is in a lot of stuff for
Chris. That was a hard stance.
(mumbles) I actually left
the Zoom without meaning to.
I think what I'm seeing
now Chris is our winner.
I mean, if you disagree
with you put it in the chat.
Let's shatter this family.
Rachel Bloom, Dave Gregor.
New baby.
They're winners, man. They got the baby.
Thank you guys so much
for taking the time out.
On a very real note, Rachel,
it's really nice to talk to you
and I appreciate you taking this time.
Dan, as well, man, it's great to see you.
Easy.
This is great.
And congratulations on
the on the new baby.
It's a what a time you've been through.
So, Thank you so much for being here.
Yeah.
Chris Redd, Thank you so much as always.
Appreciate you Be end her band.
This is great.
This, these shows have
been honestly more fun
than I thought. So, Thank you
guys so much for joining us
for Moses and friends.
We'll be back for another
one, because why not?
This is great. All right.
Stay safe. Good night.
At at the car Moses right after this.
Yeah, I know.
Listen, I got notes and your personality.
Yeah, you gotta really tone down.